running for president Ronda santz
yeah like his campaign Ronda sanz's exit
was lowkey a message on social media and
the presidential dream was over I am
today suspending my campaign I'm proud
to have delivered on 100% of my promises
and I will not stop now it's clear to me
that a majority of Republican primary
voters want to give Donald Trump another
chance I am honored to have earned your
trust and your support santis was meant
to be the next great Republican hope a
thumping win in Florida's governor's
race was to propel him to the White
House but he delayed his presidential
campaign announcement which sucked
momentum and then he botched the launch
and never really recovered as weeks and
months went by people would talk often
about his lack of Charisma how awkward
he was in person his inability to
connect with voters in these first uh
first states of Iowa New Hampshire even
South Carolina where the primary is
still over a month away on February 24th
so I think he suffered from a number of
things here thank you thanks so much he
spent tens of millions to come second in
Iowa where he predicted he would win and
with no obvious victories coming up
donors and supporters disappeared in the
cold of New
Hampshire Donald Trump was happy to Mark
the passing of the man many thought
would be his biggest rival we just got
some word that one of our opponents very
capable person is dropping out
Ron de s and Ron is dropping out and he
in doing so he endorsed us Donald
Trump's Relentless attacks on Ron
DeSantis from his positions and policies
to even the shoes that he wore strangled
the DeSantis campaign early it made him
look weak and not the confident
conservative who romed to victory in
Florida DeSantis is even now talking
about the possibility of a 2028
presidential run when there'll be no
Donald Trump in his way to torment him
and to defeat him Alan Fischer aler
Manchester New
Hampshire make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer